I'm Mark Van Lund and I'm an assistant scoutmaster with Troop 125 in Comac, New York.
This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
Have a great day and thanks for the podcast.
And now for you, Scoutmaster,
Before we get going this week, I have a pretty simple question for you.
Why is it most scouts think a nylon tent is some kind of soundproof booth?
You know what I mean. you've been in a campsite before with scouts, right?
Hey, this is podcast number 242..
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green. Let's take a look in the mailbag.
I had several responses to a post that went out this past week about constructive scouting
discipline, And if you haven't seen that one, make sure to go to scoutmastercgcom and check it out.
Bill Norton got in touch with me. He's a scoutmaster with Troop 7 in Grapevine, Texas,
And he said that is exactly what I needed to hear today. Thanks, Well, I have agents everywhere,
Bill, So hopefully we're getting the message out there that most fits the situation you
find yourself in. Bill Daniel is a scoutmastercgcom backer and he commented on that post.
your approach works wonderfully. It takes some effort to separate the boy
from the world of imposed rules to the freely adopted principle world of scouting,
And that's very well said, Bill. I appreciate that thought. The scout law gets him to think
about bigger concepts that may help with other frustrations or temptations in the future.
It's a difference between a transaction and a relationship, And we are in the
relationships that build character business. Well, I couldn't agree more, Bill, And I really
appreciate the thought. Brent Dixon is a backer and he's an assistant scoutmaster with Troop
192 in Central Florida And he wrote in about that post and said: this has been one of my
favorite posts. you've ever written excellent advice in a format that is terrific in walking
us through the steps and the logic of handling a regular experience on a camp out. Please continue
to provide posts in a similar format to that. I'm not the only scouter who is looking for practical
stories, scenario teachings that we can use to be better leaders to our scouts. Thanks for all you
do. Well, thank you, Brent. I'm going to take your advice. I'll see if I can come up with a
few similar ideas like that heard from Bobby Meadows, and he's with Troop 91 in Opelike,
Alabama. I'm writing to get your permission to use a story from podcast 120 as a recruitment tool.
The story was about a boy watching some Cub scouts scouting for food and asking if he could be a
scout. I'd like to use the clip containing that story. Thanks for your support. Well, Bobby,
I was able to locate that And, like you said, it's on podcast 120.. I sent the clip to you.
Hopefully it'll be useful for your recruiting efforts. While we're on the subject, folks,
anything that I've created has been created to further the cause of scouting, So feel free to use
it. Here's all I ask is that you attribute it to scoutmastercgcom and, where appropriate, provide
a link so that people can get back to the website and find our other resources. John Nelson is
a backer and he's an assistant scout master with Troop 947 in Westchester Ohio And he wrote
in to say I wanted to thank you for your four part series on the patrol method. for last year
or so I've been working with my troop to return to the patrol method. I joined the troop as a scout
almost 10 years ago And we've kind of moved away from the patrol method here and there. I would go
into specifics, but it would make it a really huge email. Your podcast helped me show other
scouters the big picture and they agree that the patrol method will make the troops stronger
and give our scouts a better experience. So this week our senior patrol leaders going to
sit down with the patrol leaders and talk about the patrol method. Of course there's some
loose ends that need to be tied and changes need to be made, But I know that scouts can figure this
out. Train them, trust them and let them lead, Just like Greenbar Bill said. sounds exactly like
what we're up to. I'll be sure to update you as things go along. You've heard it a thousand times,
I'm sure, but you really do make a difference for scouts and scouters everywhere. Well, thanks
so much, John. I really appreciate knowing that what we're doing is actually helping out there.
And I'll add very quickly that it doesn't really matter where you are in my troop or any troop
that I've known. We're always tying up some loose ends, We're always making improvements,
We're in a continual building and developing process as far as youth leadership is involved
and just about everything that we do. So you never get finished. That's an important part of
the nature of our work, isn't it? I want to take the time just to say a few words about
answering emails, because the pace and the volume of emails has picked up quite a bit this fall.
I do my best to answer emails the same day I receive them and I'll share maybe three or four
out of five or six here on the podcast in the hopes that they'll help other scouts with similar
questions. Make sure, when you email me, if you want me to hold what you're saying in confidence,
to let me know right there in the email. I also appreciate knowing where you are
and what unit you're involved with and what your role is. I respond to each message as I can.
The ones that are dealing with difficulties or challenges that people running into I try
and reply to as soon as I possibly can, and the more conversational or storytelling ones
it may take a little longer, But I was going through the inbox today and lining up emails
for the next several podcasts and there's really quite a backlog. So you may not
hear it on the podcast, but you'll always hear from me as soon as I possibly can get
around to replying to you. Now, while we were in the mailbag I pointed out that some
of the people who sent in emails were backers and if you're a regular reader
and listener, if the resources that we've created have helped you, you can return
the favor by becoming a scoutmastercgcom backer. The funds that we get from
backers go towards the expenses of producing and publishing the blog post
and the podcast and all the other resources that are accessible to
scouters all over the world. Now it's easy to become a backer: go to
scoutmastercgcom, click the support link at the top of the page
and you can choose from several levels of support.
some of them entitle you to premiums, like autograph copies of my books, if
if that's what you'd like to do. I want to take a moment this week to
personally thank Michael Allen, Joseph Ellis, Craig Kibler
and Mark VanLoon, who we heard just a little bit earlier,
who became backers since our last podcast. Thank you so very much, folks.
it would be impossible to make this all happen without your support.
So, once again, to become a backer, go to scoutmastercgcom.
look for the support link right there at the top of the page. become a backer
this week and I'll make sure to thank you personally during our next podcast.
So next we're going to start chipping away at the massive mountain of
email questions that we've answered in the past several weeks,
and that's going to take up the remainder of the podcast. so let's get
started, shall we?
I need your letter. send it my name
Email. that is, folks, and here's an answer to one of your emails
Heard from Carolyn Enomoto, who wrote in to ask what is your opinion about
scouts campaigning for themselves or for others
during a senior patrol leader election? Well, Carolyn, our troop holds an election
for senior patrol leader every six months and
the mechanics of that are really pretty simple. a week or so before the election,
the scout master make sure to talk with scouts who
are going to be candidates for election. it's just a. it's a very brief
conversation that confirms that they want to stand for election.
then, just before we vote, candidates for senior patrol leader get a chance to
talk to their fellow scouts and we go on from there.
we have to vote immediately. as soon as they're all done talking.
we do it in a relative amount of silence. you know as silent as scouts can be,
and that part of it is all over in about 10 or 15 minutes. it's no big deal.
it's very simple and so, uh, you know there's really not
what you would call a whole lot of room for campaigning
in the way that we do that process not, and that's the way we do things. i don't
advertise it as being the right or only way to do things, but it works for us.
i think campaigning for a troop leadership position could cut both
ways. it could be useful and it could turn into kind of a mess. right,
it all comes down to how it's handled by the scouts.
now i've never really encountered a situation where that was a problem before.
i've never really heard of scouts campaigning for election for senior
patrol leader and i don't really see a whole lot of use in it myself.
but that's just me and i'd be interested to hear from any of you that have a
different take on the subject. but, carolin, that's my best advice.
c scott anderson is a scout master for troop 96 25 and he wrote in to say
thanks again for all the good advice and the good jokes.
good jokes really, scott. i don't know about that,
you may. you might be confusing me with somebody else
as a follow-up to the podcast where we've been discussing boards of review
out of habit, perhaps our troop committee members only interact with
scouts at a border review and apart from that they're not really working with
our scouts directly. from your discussion it sounds
as though your troop committee, or at least some of them have a regular
interaction with the scouts. if the folks who form the border review
work directly with the scouts, does that end up compromising
the objectivity of the border review? well, scott, some of our committee members
are more involved in some less. our current committee chair, for example, is
there every time the doors are open and he goes camping with the troop and he's
very involved, as is our advancement chairman, for example.
so they're very involved with what's going on and they regularly interact
with scouts. i think it's pretty extraordinarily rare
and so rare that i can't recall a specific instance where there's any real
difficulty revealed at a border review. that may be
because the border review folks aren't asking the right questions, but
we rarely see any actionable problems or
feel as though the the objectivity of the judgment of the board is
compromised because the people who are sitting on the border
directly involved with the scouts. now i guess ideally
i'd like somebody who has a lot of interaction with scouts
and maybe a couple who don't on any border review
and that assures that there's some objectivity there.
many years ago we set aside one of our troop meeting nights and that's
usually the one following the weekend we go camping each month
for a patrol leaders council to meet and to plan and prepare for the next
few meetings and camping trips, and we also have a border review that
evening. usually there is always at least one scout
ready to advance and we invite scouts who haven't advanced in
some time to come and have a border review as well.
having a regular monthly border review scheduled like that
is pretty useful and it helps keep our committee members in the loop.
scott wrote back and he says: i really like the idea of more adults
interacting with the scouts and taking a more active role.
i'm just not too sure how to make that happen.
you say that scouts who aren't advancing are invited to come to a
border review. well, how exactly does that work and
how does the advancement chair know to invite them?
how do i get my advancement chair to take a more active role?
well, scott, i don't mean to be glib, but really you know, ask them to get more
involved. the advancement committee should sit down
with the guide to advancement and review their responsibilities
and then start forming strategies to carry them out.
now the scout master is kind of the gateway between the scouts and the
committee, so the scout master ought to know what's going on
and help shape those strategies by giving a little general direction. i mean, we
don't want committee members interrupting scouts, you know, during
meetings or anything like that, and they may not understand
exactly what that means. so i would suggest that
you give them some guidance when it comes to that sort of thing.
but as far as what records they keep or how they keep it and how they figure
out who to invite to boards review, as i said, start with the guide to
advancement 2013, read about the unit advancement committee
responsibilities and then start forming some strategies around that.
i know that our advancement chair keeps up with individual scouts,
looks at how they're doing and how they're advancing,
and they're able to do that without interfering with the rest of the process.
james spragley had an interesting kind of technical question,
but i think it's a useful one to discuss. he said: is there a requirement to
have toilets with running water, not just wilderness toilets, when weeblows camp
overnight with boy scouts? as a cub master, years ago, i seem to remember
there being a requirement to have facilities with running water.
does that carry forward when weeblows go on campouts with boy scout troops?
i've searched bsa publications but i really can't find anything
definitive. well, james, that turned out to be a very interesting question. so i
did a little research and there is something called the pack
overnighter site approval form and that notes
some mandatory standards that sites have to meet
to qualify as a pack overnight family camping location
and i'll make sure there's a link to that form, uh, in the post that contains
this podcast. now weeblows den leaders learn this
in owl training and i'm pretty sure owl is outdoor weeblows leader training
so i'm quoting from that syllabus. weeblows dens are encouraged to
participate in joint den troop campouts, particularly in
the fifth grade year. these campouts should be conducted with an
individual troop for the purpose of strengthening ties
between the pack and the troop. bsa, health and safety,
age, appropriate guidelines for cub scout activities
and youth protection guidelines of course apply
when camping with a troop. cub scout guides lines still
apply for all cub scout members. okay, so get that part of the cub scout
guidelines that apply when weeblows are camping with a troop
will be found on that pack overnighter site approval form.
as i said, there are some mandatory standards that sites have to meet to
qualify and those are the guidelines that apply to cub scout members
and the mandatory applicable standard on that site approval form
is that each site is within 300 feet of a sanitary toilet facility. so i don't
know exactly how to interpret that, but i would think that an outhouse or a
portable toilet or something like that would work. now i know what you're saying,
clark. are you really discussing whether or not we need toilets
right nearby when we go camping? well, i think it's a pretty interesting question
if you think about it for a moment. what's the intent of all this?
well, the intent of all these policies and all those verbiage
and training is assuring that weeblows camping with scout troops
are in age appropriate surroundings and do age appropriate activities.
in other words, we wouldn't take them on a backpacking trip or into the remote
back of beyond in a canoe. it's just not age appropriate.
so there are some things that help define
what is an age appropriate surrounding and what are age appropriate activities.
james got back to me about that. he said: yep, that helps, thank you. this is in
line with what our troop has been doing. we had
visiting weeblows camping with our troop last week on a private ranch
and had portable toilets at the campsite. next month we're doing a
backpacker and we invited weeblows out during the stay on saturday to hang
around with our scouts and do some activities in the tame areas of the
park near the car parking and bathroom facilities.
like i said, it's a little technical and it's a little.
you know it's going pretty deep into policy and
procedure, but you know these are important things
and what's really important is to get the principle that underlies them.
and once again, that is when we have weeblows camping with scout troops.
we want to make sure the surroundings and the activities are all age appropriate.
also heard from michael beck and he wrote in to say this:
i know of a few principles for resolving conflict i'd like to teach
scouts. however, how would you teach the principles of
resolving conflict using or leveraging the patrol
method? i faced a couple of situations last weekend
with scouts not getting along with each other and annoying each other
and responding to each other in unkind ways,
doing a little teasing and maybe even a little bullying,
and their parents are getting involved in all this and it's becoming a bit of a
difficulty. jumping to the parents and the scout
master is obviously not where we want to be. we want our
scouts to learn how to resolve conflicts. any advice on how to do this,
leveraging the patrol method and improving how scouts resolve conflict.
michael, the first thing i'll say is i would not teach conflict resolution,
i would promote the scout oath and law. now those both seem like
they could be exactly the same thing, but let me explain what i mean
and augment the explanation that i'm going to give you here. on the podcast
i mentioned earlier, we had a post this past week about
constructive discipline in scouting, and make sure to check that out because
it's right along the lines of what i'm going to say
now. i do a little volunteering work at our, at our local middle school,
and there's a big anti-bullying program with all kinds of anti-bullying
initiatives and this, of course, i think is a very laudable goal.
but i think it's also backfiring in some ways. students hear all about what bullying
is, how to identify it, how to resist it, and any
encouragement to better behavior comes into context of what constitutes
bullying, rather than defining good behavior on its own. do you see what i mean?
so, as the result, in the students i work with, they're quick to point out
even the least little sign of bullying in each other's speech and actions
and, oddly enough, this kind of becomes its own form of bullying,
and i think what a program like that misses, especially with students of this
age, is that when you define a negative behavior,
they're all going to try it out and or they'll become insufferably
self-righteous policemen of the problem. and the problem,
rather than the solution, becomes the focus. it becomes a thing.
it's what they end up talking about. since we're dealing with boys who are
of middle school and high school age, we're going to see the same thing in
scouting. if we start talking about problems,
that's what they're going to fixate on. if we start talking about specific
individual problems and conflicts with the troop in general,
it becomes a thing. this is what they talk about, and they kind of dissect and
they discuss and they come up with conclusions on
their own that we really might not see as being
very constructive. so the other way of handling this
is to start talking about positive things and then
that's what the scouts are going to focus on. it's pretty simple. that way,
we have all the raw material we need to do this
with the scout: oath and law. it sets the tone, it defines good conduct
and it doesn't really mention anything about bad conduct.
but i'm not telling any of you anything you don't already know, right?
so in your case, michael, i would start out by speaking with your youth leadership
and ask them what's going on and whether or not they find that kind of
behavior acceptable. tell them it's their responsibility
to promote a culture of behavior that follows the scout oath and law,
and ask them how they plan on making that happen.
now. no punishment and no discipline is allowed
and any further incidents of difficult behavior you're going to want to
hear about and then counsel that individual. and when you
counsel a scout, you really aren't trying to correct
the situation head on or resolve the conflict, because if you sit down
with a scout and you try and sort out who said what
and when they said it and what happened next,
you're really kind of end up wasting your time a little bit.
so instead of doing that, ask them to explain
what's going on and start building on an internal standard of contact,
informed by the scout oath and law, and i tell a story about that in that post
that i mentioned about constructive scouting discipline
on the blog this week. so make sure to go check that out
and you know. basically the process is: tell me about what happened,
tell me how this either adheres to or is in conflict with the different ideals
that we have in the scout oath and law. get them thinking along those lines.
then encourage them towards better behavior.
so, instead of looking at this as directly addressing conflicts
by sharing the principles of conflict resolution,
share the scout oath and law. do that relentlessly. whenever scouts behave
in a way that's consistent with the scout oath and law, talk about it.
find one thing at least to mention at the end of every
troop meeting or every time that you're standing and talking to scouts.
find something positive to say about how somebody behaved.
that's not going to end every single instance of difficult behavior,
but when you run into difficult behavior, counsel the scouts involved,
work along with them and resist the urge to talk about it
with a larger group of scouts, because in my experience what happens is
anytime we talk about that kind of conflict or difficult behavior,
they end up imitating it. it's and they do it unconsciously.
if we talk about positive things, if we talk about
how somebody followed the scout oath and law, they end up imitating that and
they do it pretty unconsciously at that age.
and the last email for this podcast comes from alan schrivener,
and alan is the scout master, troop 342 in raleigh, north carolina, and he wrote
in to say this: thank you doesn't begin to express my feeling for what you do.
you've opened my eyes to another dimension of scouting every time i
look at your site or listen to a podcast.
well thanks, alan, that i certainly appreciate that.
uh, i'm considering suggesting a change of how our troop
operates their weekly meetings, but i've made so many changes in the past two
years based on what i've learned from you- and it's your fault,
i'll accept all the fault and the blame or the credit it, it really doesn't
matter. i would like your advice on whether this
next suggestion is worth it. currently, merit badges, scout master
conferences and board's review happen at our
weekly meeting. now this makes it easy for boys to advance, but it's frustrating
my efforts to encourage the patrol method and for
scouts to fulfill their positions of responsibility because they're
frequently interrupted to go to a scout master conference or a border
review or to work on a merit badge with a counselor.
i'm thinking of suggesting, both through the troop committee and the patrol
leaders council, that adults will only be available before
on our outings and, as a compromise, perhaps just one meeting time per month.
am i looking at this through the right lens? am i trying to be too
controlling. what kind of advice do you have for me as far as this goes?
well, alan, i would say as a general rule, merit badge work doesn't belong at
troop meetings by groups or by individuals, and your example
about how distracting that is from what scouts ought to be doing during a
troop meeting is a great illustration of why that's so.
troop meetings have a different goal. therefore: planning and preparing for
outings, learning skills required for the next adventure.
now, with very few exception, i mean once or twice a year at a maximum-
we simply don't allow merit badge work to happen on troop meeting night
now once a month. as i explained in an answer uh,
before in this podcast, instead of a troop meeting
we have a patrol leaders council, border review opportunity for scout master
conferences and also an opportunity to meet
with a merit badge counselor on that night. so advancement is one of the eight
methods of scouting. it certainly should be going on.
but if you're spending as much time as it seems strictly on advancement-
and it's proving to be a distraction- your scouts are missing out on the
other seven aspects of the program. now, theoretically,
scouts ought to be finding their own merit badge counselors, scheduling
meetings with those counselors and not just having one go to counselor in
the troop because of the distraction that
causes during troop meeting. i know troop base counselors are the norm
but i think it shortcuts all of the advantages that are built into the
merit badge process in a lot of ways. so i encourage my
scouts to go outside of that small group of counselors
and you know they've been pretty successful in making that happen.
so discuss what a troop meeting night should be with your patrol leaders
council. you know, point out that you're seeing
some distractions and some difficulties with the way things are
now. talk through this with them, help them
discover some new strategies and then make some decisions about
when you do what troop meeting nights are for- troop meetings.
and that doesn't involve merit badge work and we don't want our guys distracted
by different advancement concerns and things like that.
we want them focused on what needs to happen. now, once you've had that
discussion with the patrol leaders council,
tell the other adults what's going to happen next. as i say often,
you're the scout master that they chose. you lead the other adults
and you tell them in no uncertain terms. if they have something wrong, don't be shy
about it. you have the program to back you up
now. they might not be too thrilled about this, but they picked you
as the scout master right, so i hope that helps everybody.
if you have a question for me, you can get in touch. it's easy to get in touch
and you're going to find out how to do that in just a moment.
thanks for listening to this 240 second edition of the scout master podcast.
here's how to keep in touch. read the blog at scoutmastercgcom and, while you're
there, you can subscribe to receive updates to the
blog by email. you can join the 4 000 other mobile
scouts who have the scout master app on their mobile devices
and you can get the app in google play or the itunes app store.
you can experience the wonders of scoutmastercgcom through the vast
panorama of social media. that's right. join the 6700 folks who
like scout master blog on facebook. tweet along with the course of 1100
tweeters on twitter. pin the poultry tuna's pictures
proffered publicly with 1800 other prolific pinners on pinterest
and watch us at scout master cg on youtube. or join the 400 odd folks who form
the exclusive scout master circle on google plus.
not everybody can face facebook. i understand
some people. you know twitter makes them bitter if you have no interest in
Pinterest, if you don't put the? u in youtube or you're just a minus when it
comes to google plus, that's all right. zoom into the late 90s and send me an
email. you can get in touch with me, clark green, with your
comments and questions and whatever wild ideas you might have at the time.
at clark, at scoutmastercgcom, clark is c l a r k e
and it's scoutmastercgcom. the scout master blog and the scout master
podcast are not official publications the Boy Scouts of America, nor are they
endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America,
or any other organization for that matter. i'm sure that they have better
things to do with their time. hey, it's really just me.
i have a microphone and a laptop and i'm trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and and- and you know, have a little bit of fun along the way. and speaking of fun,
here he is our founder, sir robert baydenpell. sir robert,
good luck to you and good camping, why? thank you, sir,
until next time, everyone.